ok today we're going to learn about
infrared radiation and some of its uses
so to begin with it's important to know
that infrared is a part of the
electromagnetic spectrum it's it's just
between microwaves and visible light
just like all of the other parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum it's a type of
transverse wave that travels at 300
million meters per second in a vacuum
that's the speed of light so what we're
going to do is we're going to dive
straight in and learn about some of the
uses of infrared radiation so number one
is thermal imaging so whenever we think
about infrared we often think about heat
because that's that's how a lot of heat
is transferred so if we think about the
thermal imaging it works like this
because infrared radiation is given out
by every hot object the hotter the
object the more infrared radiation it
gives out so even though we can't see it
because the only parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum we can see is
the visible light spectrum even though
we can't see it if we're if anything is
a hot object it's giving out this
radiation now obviously our eyes can't
detect it but we can use equipment
called infrared infrared cameras that
can detect this infrared radiation in
order to create an image hence thermal
imaging creating an image using heat
now often police can use it to see
suspects that are trying to escape and
hide in the dark they often have
infrared cameras fitted on helicopters
if they're chasing suspects another use
is cooking so what I've got right here
is I've got a cross-section of a toaster
and here's some bread that's been put
into the toaster so what actually can
happen
with cooking is infrared radiation is
given out by the heating elements of the
toaster so all the way across the
heating elements were given out giving
out infrared radiation now what happens
in order for this to work food absorbs
the infrared radiation and as it does it
causes it to to cook so that is how
cooking works with infrared radiation
number three is heaters so again if you
have a heater you basically it emits
lots of infrared radiation that can then
travel or transmit throughout the room
it basically transfers lots of energy to
the thermal store of different objects
causing their temperature to increase
you do need to know though that if you
have too much of this infrared radiation
it is absorbed by the skin
and it can cause burns so infrared
radiation can be dangerous because it
can cause burns okay next up we have
remote controls so the first three kind
of demonstrates infrared radiation in
terms of heat or in terms of yet in
terms of heat but we can also use it to
transfer information so lots and lots of
remote controls use infrared radiation
in order to transfer information so when
you press the buttons on your remote it
Tran it emits infrared radiation which
can then be picked up by receiver within
let's say your television now the reason
why that it it works for this is
basically the distances need to be
fairly small and it must be in the line
of sight so you can't really turn on
off your TV for devices that are next
door for example now the final one we
need to know about the final use is
optical fibers
now optical fibers are thin glass or
plastic fibers that carry data for
example for telephones and computers
they travel they kind of transfer that
carry the data over long distances
now what happens is the infrared travels
along the wire along the optical fiber
using a process referred to as total
internal reflection and you can learn
more about that in another video so
essentially those are the five uses of
infrared radiation we need to know about
thermal imaging cooking heaters remote
controls and optical fibers and a
dangerous thing about infrared radiation
is our skin can absorb it so infrared
radiation can cause burns thank you